um okay welcome everyone um to week four we're into now um so for today what I want to do is first of all um well a couple more bits on machine translation especially just talking a little bit about evaluating machine translation then I want to spend a while on attention so attention is a very um fun mental concept and of newal networks which was originally developed in the context of machine translation there also then a very um Central concept when we're talking about Transformers which
we then start talking about on Thursday okay so um getting straight into it um so this is the picture that we saw towards the end of last time that this is how we were baking uh machine translation system where we are using um a multi-layer lstm where we're feeding in a source sent sentence and then we were flipping um to um then turning the model into a decoder with different parameters which would generate one word at a time to generate the translated sentence um so um here I've got an
German sentence and it's produced an English translation that looks a pretty good one and but you know we're going to want to have a way of deciding well are we um producing good translations or not um and so we need some way to evaluate machine translation now this is a complex area because you know if you start poking around in the literature um people have proposed literally hundreds of different measures that could be used to evaluate machine translation systems I'm of writing a couple of papers on it
myself so I'm contributed to the problem um but you know by far the most commonly common measure that you see to this day was essentially the first measure proposed to automatically evaluate machine translation which was the blue measure um which was um proposed to understand for bilingual evaluation underst study though it went along with the fact that was proposed by IBM probably not coincidence um so until this point um the only way that people had really used for evaluating translations was getting human beings to
look at them and say how good of a translation this is and you know that's still a gold standard measure that is widely used um for evaluating translations because you know many of the automatic measures have various kinds of um biases and problems that make human evaluation useful but on the other hand um a lot of the time we'd like to you know iterate quickly on evaluations we'd like to use evaluations and training loops and things like that and I the IBM people with the blue paper suggests well maybe
we can come up with a halfway decent automatic method of um doing translations and the idea of what they proposed was this that we're going to have one or more reference translations for a piece of text so these are human written translations and then we can score any automatic translation mainly on how often they have overlapping one 2 three and four grams uh the number four isn't special you could have only gone up to three or five but four we seen as a reasonable length um overlapping um n
gs with one of the reference translations and the more overlap you have the better um and we we this discussion of this evaluation in the assignment so you can think about it a bit more and I won't go actually through all the formulas right now um but you know that's most of it um and so here's um a picture of how that looks so the original idea was what we should do is you know have several reference translations and then we'd get a machine translation and then we'd look at this
machine translation and try and find pieces of it in the reference translation so we can certainly find the unigram the um we can't find American at all but we can find International Airport and its in the second reference translation so we're going to get a 4 g match for that um we can find that again that's easy office all receives one call Self the sand Arab I'm not of very good translation this right so that all misses but then you start to find other pieces um that do overlap and you use
those to work out a score um the original idea was you should always have multiple reference translations so that you can sample the space of possible translations and have reasonable coverage in practice for what's been done more recently it's not so uncommon that people do this with one reference translation and the argument then is still on a kind of a probabilistic basis the more often you have a good translation the more often you'll get matches and therefore your score will be
better yeah so um why you know why did people come up with this and why is it still imperfect well the problem with translation is that there isn't one right answer it's not like the kind of classification things you see in machine learning where you show people a picture and the right answer is to say this the class of this object um is whatever labut or right dog breeds or something right that for any sentence there are many different ways to translate it and you know translators can sit around and argue that oh this
phrasing is a little bit nicer than this phrasing blah blah blah but to a first approximation you can translate sentence in lots of ways um and those different ways of translation can involve different word orders so you can't really sort of check the words off as you come down in the sentence and that's what motivated this idea of sort of matching engrams anywhere so you can get reasonable credit um for having the right matches but you know nevertheless it's a pretty crude version of it right
um you know you can still get a poor blue score for good translation just because the words you chose didn't happen to match a reference translation and also you can get points for things without really having a good translation at all right if you just have words that match even if they're having completely the wrong role in the sentence you will get some points but it's harder to get engram matches unless you're um for larger n unless you're using words the right way um there's one other tricken
the blue measure that there's a penalty for two short system translations CU otherwise you could leave out everything difficult and only translate the easy part of the sentence and then for the bits you have translated um you could then be getting a high score for the Precision of those pieces okay so we'll use when you're developing your Mt systems for assignment three um we'll use them with blue um so so um now we have a evaluation measure um we can um start looking at how well
um how well do systems do on a blue score and blue scores are theoretically between zero and 100 but you're never going to get to 100 because of the variations of how you can translate things um and so typically if you can start to get to the 20s uh translations uh you can sort of understand what the source document was about um once you get into the 30s and 40s the translations are getting much much better um yeah so um statistical phrase-based translation was pioneered um by IBM in the late 90s actually and was sort of
redeveloped in the 2000's decade and was what Google launched as Google Translate in the 2000th decade and it continued to be worked on for sort of the following decade but there was basically a strong sense um that progress in Translation had doing statistical phrase based systems had basically stalled that it got a little bit better each year as people could build traditional Ingram language models with more data every year and things like that but the numbers were barely going upwards um so
in the years from about 2005 to 15 or maybe 14 the dominant idea in the machine translation Community was the way we were going to get um better machine translation is doing syntax-based machine translation if we actually knew the structure of sentences and we'd pass them up then we'd know what the role of words was in sentences and then we'd be able to translate much better and this was particularly invoked by looking at languages where trans worked terribly so in those days translation worked sort of okay for
languages like French to English um or Spanish to English which are kind of sort of similar European languages um but the results worked way worse for Chinese to English or German to English and even though English is a Germanic language German has a very different word order um to English with commonly verbs at the end of a clause and different elements being fronted and so there was it wasn't so people tried to work on um um grammar-based syntax based methods of statistical machine translation and I was one of those who
worked on those in the late 2000s decade but you know the truth is it sort of didn't really work right if the rate of progress in um syntax-based um machine translation was had slightly more slope um than phrase based machine translation over these years the amount of slope um wasn't very much so things were completely then thrown on their head um when neural machine translation got invented because as I explained you know the first attempts were in 2014 the first cases in which it was evaluated and boff evaluations was
2015 and so in 2015 it wasn't as good as the best other machine translation methods but by 2016 it was and it was just on this much much steeper slope of getting way way better and that this graph only goes up to 2019 um but it's continued to go up and so it's not that uncommon these days that you see blue numbers in the 50s and 60s um for new or machine translation systems so that's a good news story um so after this I want to go on and sort of introduced this um idea of attention
um which is now a very fundamental important idea in neural systems it's also interesting because it's actually something novel that was invented kind of recently so for everything that we've done in new networks up until now really it had all been invented before the turn of the Millennium right so um basic feed Ford neural networks recurrent neural networks lstms other things that we haven't yet haven't talked about like convolutional newal networks they were all invented last Millennium it was really a waiting
game at that point until there was sufficient data and computational power for them really to show that how good they were um but attention was something that actually got invented in 2014 in the origins of neural machine translation and it proved to be a very transformative idea for making neural networks more powerful um so the idea of what motivated attention was looking at exactly this kind of machine translation problem so we're running our lstm over the source sentence and then we were
using this hidden State as the previous hidden state that we're feeding into the generator lstm for the T Target sentence and what that means is everything useful about this sentence has to be stuffed into that one vector and well that's maybe not so hard if you've got a four-word sentence but you know maybe you've got a 40w sentence out here and it seems to be kind of implausible that it' be a good idea to be trying to fit everything about that sentence into this one hidden State and well obviously
there are crude solutions to this you make the hidden state bigger and then you've got more representational space you use a multi-layer lstm you've got more representational space but it still seems a very questionable thing to do and it's certainly not like what a human being does right like if a human being is translating a sentence they read the sentence and they've got some idea of its meaning but as they start to translate they look back at the earlier parts of the sentence and make use of
that in their translation and so that doesn't seem like it's a very plausible model so the idea should be that our new network should be able to attend to different things in the source um so that they can get information as needed looking back in the sentence and so this is the idea of attention so on each step of the decoder we're going to insert direct connections to the encoder so we can look at particular words in the sentence um so I've got a bunch of diagram sentences that go through what
we do and then after that I'll present the equations that go along with this okay so once we're starting to translate um we've got a hidden State at the start of our generator and then we're going to use this hidden State as our key to look back into the encoder to try and find useful stuff so we're going to compare in a way I'll make precise later the hidden state with the hidden State at every position um in the source sentence and based on our comparisons we're going to work out an attention
score where where should we be looking at in the source sentence while generating the here the first word of the translation and So based on these attention scores we'll stick them into a soft Max as we commonly do and we'll then get a probability distribution or a waiting over the different positions in the sentence and then we will use this waiting to compute a representation based on the encoder um which is then going to be a weighted average of the encoder St dates so in this particular case it'll be
nearly entirely the representation above the first word eel which means he in French um so then we'll take that attention output um and we'll combine it um with the hidden state of our decoder and we'll use both of them together to generate an output Vector which we stick through our soft Max and generate a word as the first word of the translation y one and so then at that point we just repeat this over um so we then go on to generating the second word um well you know we copy down the first word generator start to
generate the second word we work out attention at every position um it gives us um an oh sorry there's a little note there which little fine point which maybe I won't deal with but it points out sometimes you um also do things like stick the previous time steps attention output into the next step as an extra input and we actually do that in it should say assignment three there that's buggy um so there are other ways to use things but I'll sort of gloss over that um so um we generate another word and we
sort of repeat over and at each time step we're looking at different words in the source and they will help us to translate the sentence yeah wait wait say again why is it bring bring point the green okay the so the the green Vector the hidden Vector of the coder is going to be used together with the hidden States the hidden vectors of the encoder one at a time to calculate the attention scores so the attention score at a position is going to be a function of the Hidden state of the encoder at that position and the
current hidden state of the decoder and I'll explain exactly how in a moment thank you any other questions okay um well so here it is in math okay so we have um encod of hidden states which we're going to call H um so we have decoder hidden states which we're going to call S so there're something different um and we're going to at each point being some particular time step T so we'll be dealing with st um so to calculate the attention scores um for generating uh then word for time step T
we're going to calculate an attention score for each position in the encoder okay um I'll discuss alternatives for this in a moment but the very easiest way to calculate an attention score which is shown here is to take a DOT product between the hidden state of the encoder and the current hidden state of the decoder and so that's what we're showing here so that will give us some dot product score which is just any number at all um then the next thing we do is we stick those ET scores into our softmax
distribution and that gives us our probability distribution as to how much weight to put on each position in the encoder and so then we are calculating the weighted average of the encoder hidden States um which we're just doing with the obvious equation that we're taking the weighted sum of the Hidden states of the encoder based on the attention weights and then what we want to do is concatenate our our our tension output and the hidden state of the decoder and we're going to which is
giving us then a double length vector and then we're going to feed that into um producing the next word from the decoder so typically that means we're multiplying that vector by another Matrix and then putting it through a soft Max um to get a probability distribution over um words to output and choosing the highest probability word okay um that make sense I hope yeah um okay so attention is great so inventing this idea was completely transformative um so the very first modern neural machine translation system
was done at Google in 2014 and they used a pure but very large very deep um lstm so was an eight layer deep lstm with a very large Hidden State for the time um and they were able to get good results um but very shortly thereafter um people at the University of Montreal dimma bad now K huno and Yoshua Benjo um did a second version of machine translation um using attention and with a much more modest compute budget of the kind that you can afford in universities um they were able to get better results
because attention was their secret um thing so attention significantly improved nmt performance and essentially every new machine translation um System since has used attention like we've just seen um you know it's more human like as I was indicating because it's sort of what a human would do you'd look back in the sentence to see what you need to translate um and it solves this bottleneck problem you now no longer have to stuff all the information about the source sentence into one hidden
State you can have the whole of your representational space from your entire encoding and use it as you need it um it also helps with the vanishing gradient problem this is connected to what I was saying NE last time when talking about res ual connection so of a way out of the banishing gradient problem is to direct connect things and this provides shortcut connections to all of the Hidden states of the encoder and another nice thing that attention does is it gives you some interpretability so by looking at where
the model is um attending you can basically see what it's translating at different time steps and so that can be um really useful and so it's kind of like we can see what We're translating where without explicitly having trained A system that does that so for my little toy sentence here if he hit me with a pie you know at the first position um it's you know it was looking at the first word eel he which it translates um then there's in French this there's this sort of verb on
T to sort of pie somebody I guess in English as well you can use pie as a verb right so so um the a is a is a sort of perfect past um exiler so sort of like he has me pied is what the French words are one at a time and so the hit is already looking at the pi then the me is attending to the m which means me and then all the with with the piie is attending still to Anar which is basically the right kind of alignment that you want for words of a sentence so that's pretty cool um too okay um so I presented up until this
point um just this um said oh we could do a DOT product but you know in general there's more to it than that so what we have is we have some values H1 to hn and we have a query vector and we want to work out how to do a tension based on these things so attention always involves Computing some attention scores and taking the soft Max to get an attention distribution and then getting an attention output but the part where there's variation is how do you compute these attention scores and a
number of different ways have been done for that and I just want to go through that a little bit um so the simplest way that I just presented is this dot product attention we just take the hidden States and Dot product the whole of them um and that sort of works um but it doesn't actually work great and I sort of discussed this a bit when talking about lstms last time right that you know the the hidden state of an lstm is its complete memory right so it has to variously store lots of things in that
memory it's got to be storing information that'll help it output the right word it has to be storing information about the future about other things that you'll want to say given the kind of sentence context grammar and previous words you've said right you sort of got all kinds of memory and so it sort of makes sense that some of it would be useful for linking up for looking back and some of it would be less useful you sort of want to find the parts that are related to what you want
to say immediately not all the parts that um do all of the rest of the future um so that suggested um maybe you could do a more general form of um attention and so tanglong and me in 201 2015 suggested maybe we could introduce um what we called by linear attention which um I still think is a better name but the rest of the world came to call multiplicative attention um where what we're doing is between these two vectors um we're sticking a matrix um and so we're then learning the parameters of
this Matrix just like everything else in our neural network and so effectively this Matrix can learn which parts of the um generator hidden State you should be looking to find where in the hidden states of the encoder in particular it no longer requires that things have to match up Dimension by Dimension you know it could be the case that the encoder is storing information about word meaning here and the and the decoder is storing information about word meaning here and by learning appropriate parameters in
this Matrix um we can sort of match those together and work out the right place to pay attention so that seemed um kind of a cool approach to us um yeah why don't go all in with Even build like a neural network that's GNA H input and output um you can do that I was going to get to that on the next slide um actually that's in a way sort of going backwards but I I will get to it on the next slide but before I do that um I will uh um show you um these other versions so the the dis the one thing you might
wonder about um doing it this way is you know there's a lot of parameters that you have to learn in The Matrix W you know there aren't that many in my example because they're only 36 but that's because my hidden states are only of length six right and if your hidden states are of length a thousand say then you've got a million parameters in that um W Matrix and that seems like it might be kind of problematic and so the way to get beyond that which was fairly quickly suggested thereafter is well maybe
rather than having that whole big Matrix in the middle instead what we could do is form it as a low rank Matrix and the easy way to make a low rank Matrix is you take two skinny matrices like this where this is the rank of these of the pieces and multiply them together which would give us the big Matrix that I showed on the last slide and so this gives you a low parameter um version of um the um bilinear attention Matrix from the last slide but at that point if you just do a teeny bit of linear algebra
this computation is exactly the same as saying well what I'm going to do is I'm going to take each of these two vectors and project them to a lower dimensional space using this low rank transformation matrix and then I'm going to take the dot product in this low dimensional space um and uh on Thursday when you get to Transformers um what you will see that Transformers do is this that they're taking um the big vector and they're projecting it to a low dimensional space and then taking dot product um attention
in that low dimensional space okay um back to the question um yeah you're totally right and you know at this point I'm going um sort of you know in an ahistorical manner because yeah actually the first form of attention that was proposed in the B hour Al paper um was hey um let's just stick a little new net there to calculate attention scores so um we take the the S and the H we multiply them both by a matrix add them put them through a tan H multiply that by a vector um and we get a number you know
this looks just like the kind of comput ations we've use everywhere else in an lstm so there's a little neural net that's calculating the attention scores and then they go into a softmax as useful usual um in most of the literature this is called additive attention which also seems to be a really weird name I mean I think kind of saying you've got a little new net um makes more sense um for that one um so but anyway so this is what they proposed and used um and and you know at this point it's a little bit um complex
to be honest I mean you know um so like when we wrote our paper the next year we had found that the um bilinear attention worked better for us um but there was subsequent work especially this massive exploration of new machine translation architectures that argued that actually um with the right kinds of uh good hyperparameter optimization actually this is the best kind this is better than the bilinear tension but you know this is a lot more complex and a lot slower um than doing what you're
doing in the upper part of the chart so regardless of whether it's better or not in practice what's completely one is doing this and this is what Transformers use and just about all other new Nets that are used these days okay um questions on attention will be found in assignment three um yeah so um I won't say much more about this now and you know we'll see more of it just next lecture um but attention is a very general technique right it was a great way to improve machine translation and
that was how it was first invented but you know for all kinds of new architectures for all kinds of purposes you can stick attention to into them and the general finding was that always improved results so in general anywhere where you have a a vector of values a vector query and you can use attention to then sort of get a weighted average of the values which finds relevant information that you can use to improve your performance um and so maybe maybe I won't try and even give examples of that
now um but you'll sort of see another example of attention immediately when we do things on T on Thursday where um we then sort of start doing self attention inside transformers yes in the you also try nonlinearity um no we did not ah I mean it didn't seem especially necessary I don't know but no we did not okay um well this is the end of um the part with attention are there any other questions yes um for the RNN attention stuff is there a need for positional information or is that not required to
solve the for positional information um so so there was none and it seemed like it wasn't very required I mean you could yeah I mean you could make some inform you could make some argument that maybe position information um might have been useful but there's also a good argument that it wasn't necess Neary and the sort of recent everywhere usage of positional information only becomes necessary when you get to a Transformer and the reason for that is you know going back to the pictures
um for these encoder States they're being calculated with respect to the previous encoded estate right because it's a current newal Network and therefore the representation here knows something about the past so it kind of knows what position it's in basically and so that you know that's giving a lot of that information or another way to think about it is this final representation will give a certain overall sense of the semantics of the sentence and so to the extent that you're looking backwards the more sort
of associative matching of similar semantic content that's needed seems sufficient you don't really need additional positional information okay I will go on okay um so that's the um that's the new Network's content for today um and so for the remaining 39 minutes um I want to talk final projects but also a bit about um data experiments and things like that okay so this is a reminder on the class so um we've got the four assignments which are 48% and then the big other part of what
you need to do um is the final project which is 49% almost completing things out except for the participation um and um let me just give one note back to um collaboration the honor code I mean for final projects it's quite use usual that people use all sorts of stuff that were written by other people that's completely fine we don't expect you to implement everything from scratch um but you must document what you're using you know give references or URLs if you're using other
people's code rather than writing your own we do not want to know what code you wrote yourself and what things you downloaded from pie um and in particular in thinking about final projects um the question of interest for us is what value add did you provide right so you haven't done something great if you've downloaded a really good neural network and run it on some data and it produces really good results that's not much value ad um so if you want to have value ad in that context you at least want to
be doing something interesting about understanding um why it works so well what kind of examples it doesn't work well on doing some thorough experimental analysis um yeah a couple of other points there um okay so for the final project um for this class um there's a binary um choice you can either do our default final project which I'll talk about more a bit later or you can come up with your own final project and I'll talk about that a bit too um so um we allow team size of 1 to three um the complicated thing that
comes up um oh actually sorry I should say the other point first um yeah so if you do um we we generally encourage people to form teams it means that you can do something more interesting it's more motivational you can make friends whatever um so teams are good um on expectations for teams um our expect for teams is that a bigger team should be able to do proportionately more work now and so when we're grading things we expect to see more work from larger teams um now how this works out is kind
of I will admit a little bit complicated because you know there's sort of a quality issue that's separate from the amount of work um so you know the reality is that it's just always the case that several of the very best projects are one person efforts because they're just somebody who has a good idea and knows what they want to do and does it by themselves and it is great um but you know they're also great multi-person projects as well but um the point I'm meaning is well if you know it
kind of doesn't work if you're a oneperson project and you try and attempt a huge amount of stuff and you can only get onethird of the way through it um that's not a good recipe for doing well in the final project um for any project um you really need to sort of be completing something and showing something but you know nevertheless if you're one person and you can show something kind of interesting even if our reaction is oh well this would have been much better if they' shown it was
better than this other kind of model or it would have been really nice if they' run ablations to work things out well if you're one person will give you a buy and say oh but it was only one person um whereas if you're a three-person team and it seems like you obviously should have compared it to some other models and you obviously could have run it on some other data sets um then we'll feel like well as a three-person team um they obviously should have done that and therefore we should give them um a less
good score and that's how that is a worked out um the complication comes um with other things people are doing at the same time we allow people to do final projects um that are shared with multiple classes um but you know expectation is again that you'll do more work so if there are two of you who are using one project for both this class and cs231 and say then it's sort of like it's a four-person project and you should be doing a lot of work for it um there are other cases sometimes people
have ra ships or their PHD rotation students or other things if you're doing it for other things we'd like you to tell us and we expect you to be um doing um more work for it um okay um I'm very happy to talk to people about final projects and have been talking to people about final projects but unfortunately there's only one of me so I definitely can't talk to 500 people about final projects so I do also encourage you to um talk to all of the Tas about final projects so on the
um office hours page under all of the Tas there's some information about things that they know about um so if you know what your projects is about you could at least try and find one of the most useful Tas or just find a TA with a friendly face um whatever mechanism you use talk to Tas about um final projects yeah so default final project so what it's going to be um is so Bert was a famous early um Transformer and we're going to be sort of building and experimenting with a minimal bir
implementation so if you do this um there's part of a a part of an implementation of bird and you're meant to finish it off and you're meant to fine-tune it and get some data results um for doing sentiment analysis and then basically um we want the even the default final project to be an open-ended project where people can do different things and so then there's lots of other ideas or you can come up with your own of ways you could extend um this system and make it better which might be with paraphrasing contrast of
learning low rank adaptation something and you can do something and that is your final project um so why choose the final project so if you haven't had much experience with research um you don't have any real idea of what you want to do for a final project um or you'd like something with clear guidance and a goal and a leaderboard because we provide a leaderboard for people doing the default final project of how good your performance is on the tasks we provide then you can do the final project and I
mean honestly I think for many people the best option um is to do the final project um for sort of past performance typically about half the students do the final project including some Pro people who um start off thinking I'll do a custom final project then after a couple of weeks they decide H this makes no sense what I was suggesting it's not working at all I'm just going to abandon and flip to the default final project um okay but we also allow custom final projects and there are good reasons to
do custom final projects so if you have some um topic or research idea that you're excited about maybe you're already even working on it or you want to try something different on your own um or You' just like to have more of the experience of trying to come up with a research goal finding the necessary data and tools and starting from scratch which is actually very educational if considerably harder um well then the custom final project um is fine for you um restriction on topics I think we'd
already sort of signal this on AED um we insist for um cs224n final projects that they have to substantively involve both human language and new networks you know because this is the NLP class um so we'd like people to know and learn something about human language um I'm totally aware of the fact that you can use these same models for bioinformatic sequences um or music or um uh radar whatever but we'd like you to do something with human language for this class um that doesn't mean it has to be
only about human language so people have done things like visual language models um or music and language um so it can have a combination of modalities um but it has to you know substantively not completely trivially involve human language if You' got any questions about that ask and it also has to substantively involve neural networks though again it doesn't have to be holy about neural networks if you've got some ideas thinking oh I think I could show using kernel machines that they work
just as well as having multiannual networks or something like that that's of course fine to do as well um gamesmanship um yeah the default final project is more guided but it's not meant to be a complete Slackers ride we're um hoping that people do the same amount of work for either kind of project but on the other hand it does kind of give you sort of a clearer focus and course of things to do but it is still an open-ended project um so you know for both um default final projects and custom final projects there are
great projects and there are not so great projects um you know if anything there's a bit more variance in the custom final project so you know the path of success is not to do some try and do something for a custom final project um that just looks really weak compared to people's default final projects um okay um you can get good grades either way um we get give best project Awards um to both kinds of projects so yeah it's really not that there's some secret one you have to pick
um Computing um yeah so um to be honest with the confessions right at the beginning we're actually in a less good position um for computing than we've been in recent years and it's all open AI fault no that part um but you know up until and including last year um we were actually had invariably managed to get um very generous um cloud computing giveaways from one or other cloud computing provider which really um provided a lot of um Computing support but you know there's the great GPU shortage on at the
moment due to the Great success of large language models and it turns out that um Cloud compute providers just aren't being as generous as they used to be and gee I guess the AWS rep was pointing out um that my course was their single largest Grant of free GPU last year so it's getting harder to do um so um so um really people will have to um patch things together more in many cases and so we'll be relying on the Ingenuity of students to be able to find free and cheap stuff um so um Google is giving
$50 credit per person on gcp which can be used for assignments 34 and the final project um on all the clouds if you haven't used a cloud with an account before you can usually get some free starter credits um which can be a useful thing um there are um the sort of jup notebooks in the cloud so um the most used one is Google collab um which allows limited GPU use um it often tends to get tighter later in the quarter um so you might find it a good investment to not have a couple of lattes and pay
10 bucks a month to get collab Pro which gives you much better access to G um gpus um but there are alternatives to that which you might also want to look at so AWS provid provides a Jupiter notebook environment s maker studio lab um and you know also owned by Google kegle separately provides kegle notebooks um which actually commonly give you better GPU access than Google collab provides even though um you know they're otherwise not as nice kegle notebooks are sort of just um Bare Bones Jupiter notebooks whereas
collab has some fancier um UI stuff grafted on it um so other possibilities um modal is a low price GPU provider and allows and a a certain amount of free GPU usage a month so that could be handy um there are other lower cost GPU providers like vast AI which could be of relevance um and then the other thing that I'll say more about in a minute is you know the way things have changed with large language models there are lots of projects that you might want to do where you're not actually building
models at all yourself but you're wanting to you know do experiments on large language models or you're wanting to do in context learning with large language models um or other things of that sort um and then what you want is to have access to large language models and in particular you probably want to use have API access so you can automate things so another thing that we have been able to get um is through the generosity of together AI that together AI is providing $50 of API access to um
large language models which can actually be a lot um how much of a lot it is depends on how bigger model you're using so something you should um think about is how big a model do you really need to use to um show something because if you can run a 7 billion parameter language model um on together you know you can put a huge huge number of tokens through it for 50 bucks whereas if you want to run a much bigger model um then you know the number of tokens start you can get through it goes down by orders of
magnitude um so that's good um and I mentioned some other ones so we've already put a whole bunch of documents um up on Ed that talk about these different um GPU options so do look at those okay um jumping ahead so the first thing you have to do as a project proposal um so it's one per team so I guess the first step is to work out who your team is um and so for the project proposal part of it is actually giving us the details of your project but there's another major part of it which
is writing a review of a key research paper for your topic so what um for the default final project we provide some suggestions so you can find something else if you've got another idea for how to extend the project um for your custom project you're finding your own but what we want you to do is get some practice at looking at a research paper understanding what it's doing understanding what's convincing what it didn't consider what it failed to do and so we want you to write a two-page
summary of a research paper and the goal is for you to be thinking critically about this re search paper you know of what did it do that was exciting versus what did it claim was exciting but was really obvious or perhaps even wrong Etc okay um and then right so then a so um after that you know we want you to say what you're planning to do that may be very straightforward for a default final project but it's really important um for a custom final project um and in particular um you know tell us about you
know the literature you're going to use if any and the kind of models you're going to explore but you know it turns out that when we're unhappy with custom final projects the two commonest complaints about um what you tell us about custom final projects is you don't make clear what data you're going to use because we're sort of worried already if you haven't worked out by the project proposal deadline what data you can use for your final project and if you don't tell us how you're going to evaluate
your system we want to know how you're going to measure whether you're getting any success um as a new thing this year um we'd like you to include an ethical considerations paragraph outlining potential ethical challenges of your work if it were deployed in the real world and how that might be mitigated um this is something that now a lot of conferences are requiring and a lot of Grants are requiring um so w't give you a little bit of practice on that by writing a paragraph of that um how much
there is to talk about various somewhat on what you're trying to do and whether it has a lot of ethical problems or whether it's a fairly straightforward question answering system but in all cases you might think about what are the possible ethical consider ations of this piece of work okay the whole thing is maximum four pages um okay so for the um research paper summary yeah do think critically right I mean the worst the the worst um summaries are essentially people that just paraphrase
what's in the abstract and introduction of the paper and we want you to think a bit harder about this you know what were the novel contributions of the paper um is it something that you could use for different kinds of problems and different ways or was it really exploiting a trick of one data set um are there things that it seemed like they missed or could have done differently or you weren't convinced were done properly um is it similar or distinctive to other papers that are dealing with the same topic
does it suggest perhaps something that you could try that extends beyond the paper um okay and for grading these final project proposals most of the points are on that paper review and so do pay attention to it um there are some points on the project plan but you know really we're wanting to mainly give you formative feedback on the project plan and comments as to how we think it's realistic or unrealistic um but nevertheless um we're expecting you to sort of have an idea have thought
through how you can investigate it thought through how you can evaluate it data sets baselines things like that oh yeah I should emphasize this do have an appropriate Baseline so for anything that you're doing you should have something you can compare it against so sometimes it's a previous system that did exactly the same thing but if you're doing something more novel and interesting you should be thinking of some seat of the pants obvious way to do things and proving that you can do it
better and what that is depends a lot on what your project is but you know if you're building some complex new net um that's going to be used to work out textural similarity between two pieces of text well a simple way of working out textual similarity between two pie pieces of text is to look up the word vectors for every word in the text and average them together and work out um the dot product between those average vectors and unless your complex newal network is significantly better than
that it doesn't seem like it's a very good system so you should always attempt to have some baselines um after um the project proposal we also have a project Milestone Stuck in the Middle to make sure everybody um has making some progress this is just to help make sure people um do get through things and keep working on it so we'll have good final projects um for most final projects I'll say more about this in a minute we The crucial thing we expect for the Milestone is that you
know you've kind of got set up and you can run something it might just be your Baseline of looking up the word vectors but means you've kind of got the data and the framework and something that you can run and produce a number from it um and then there's the final project um we have people submit their code for the final projects but final projects are um evaluated almost entirely unless there's some major worries or concerns based on your project report so make sure you put time into the project report which is
essentially a research paper like a conference paper and they can be up to eight pages and it varies on what you're doing but you know this is the kind of picture typically of what um Pap will look like will'll have an abstract and introduction it'll talk about other related work it'll present the model you're using the data you're using and your experiments and their results and have some insightful comments in its analysis and conclusion at the end okay um finding research topics um for
custom projects um all kinds of things you can do you know basic philosophy of science you're normally either starting off with here's some problem I want to make some progress on or here's this cool idea for a theoretical technique um or change in something and I want to show it's better than other ways of doing it and you're working from that um we allow different kinds of projects um you know one common type of project is you've got some task of interest and you're going to try and solve it or make
progress on it somehow that you want to you know get information out of state department documents um and you're going to see how well you can do it with neural NP a second kind is you got some ideas of doing something different with newal networks and then you going to see how well it works um or maybe given there are large language models these days you're going to see how using large language models you can do something interesting by in context learning or building a larger language model program
so NE you know nearly all um 224n projects are in those first three types where at the end of the day you've got some kind of system and you've got some kind of data and you're going to evaluate it um but that's not a 100% requirement there are different kinds of projects you can do and a few people do so you can do an analysis interpretability project um you could be interested in something like how could these Transformer models possibly understand what I say to them and give the right answers to my statements let
me try and look inside the neural networks and see what they're Computing how recently there's been a lot of work on this topic often under um titles like mechanistic interpretability um circuit training and things like that so you can do some kind of analysis or interpretability project or you could even just do it um looking at the behavior of models of some task so you could take some linguistic task like metaphor interpretation and see which neural networks can interpret them correctly and which can't or which kinds
of ones they can interpret correctly or not and do things like that um another kind is a theoretical um project occasionally people have done things um looking at the behavior of well what's a good example um somewhere that's in the math so an example that was actually done a few years ago and turned into a conference paper was looking at in the estimation of word vectors the stability of um the word vectors that were computed by different algorithms word Toc versus glove um and um deriving results with
proofs about the stability um of the um um vectors that were calculated um so that's loud but we don't see many of those um here very quickly um it's sort of just sort of random things so a lot of past projects you can find on the 224n web page you can just find different past year reports um and you can look at them to get ideas as you wish um so deep poetry um was a gated lstm where the idea was as well as sort a language model that generated success of words they had extra stuff in it to
make it um rhyme in a um poetry like pattern that was kind of fun um you can do a reimplementation of a paper um that has been done previously this is actually kind of an old one but I remember it well so back in the days before Transformers um deep minded these kind of interesting papers on newal chur machines and differentiable neural computers um and um but they didn't release implementations of them um and so Carol set about writing her own implementation of a differentiable neural computer which in a way was a a
little bit crazy um and a few days before the deadline she still hadn't gone at working so it could have been a complete disaster um but she did get it working before the deadline and got it to run producing some interesting results um so that was kind of cool so it if it's something interesting it doesn't have to be original it can be sort of reimplementing something interesting um okay um sometimes um papers do get published later as interesting ones this was a paper that was sort of again from the
early days and was sort of fairly simple but you know it was a novel thing that gave progress so the way we've sort of presented these rnm you have sort of word vectors at the bottom and then you kind of compute the soft Max at the top but if you think about the sort of multiplying by the output Matrix and then putting that into the softmax that output Matrix is also like a set of word vectors because you have a column for each word and then you put it to you get a score for each output word and then
you're putting a soft Max over that um and so their idea was well maybe you could sort of share those two um sets of vectors and you'd be able to get improvements from that and you could um okay maybe I won't talk about that one um sometimes people have worked on quantized models that's sort of more of a um a sort of a general new network technique but providing you show you can do useful things with it like have good language modeling results even with quantize vectors we'll count that as
using language um so in recent times um these two last tour from 2024 um you know a lot of the time people are doing projects with pre-trained large language models which we will be talking about in the next three models three lectures and then doing things with them and so you can do lightweight parameter efficient fine-tuning methods you can do in context learning methods and things like this and I suspect that probably quite a few of you will do projects um of um this kind so you know here's an example
so lots of work has been done on producing um code language models um and so um these people um decided to improve um the generation of Fortran maybe they are physicist I don't know and um so um they were able to show that they could um use parameter efficient fine-tuning to improve code llama for producing for now where was the natural language um code has natural language comments in it and the comments can be useful for explaining what you want the code to do and so it was effectively doing um translation from
human language um explanation of what the code code was meant to do into pieces of code um here was another one um which um was um doing AI fashion driven cataloging um transforming images into textual descriptions which again was starting off with an existing visual language model and looking at how to fine-tune it okay um other places to look for stuff um so you know you can get kind of lots of ideas of areas and things people do by looking at past papers they you're also welcome to have your own original
ideas thinking about anything you know or work on in the world so for NLP papers there's a site called the ACL Anthology that's good for them for there are lots of papers on language that also appear in machine learning conferences so you can look at the neurs or I clear proceedings you can look at past 2 24n projects and then um the archive pre-print servers got tons of papers on everything including NLP and you can look there but I do actually think it's you know some of the funnest best
projects are actually people that find their own problem which is an interesting problem in their world you know if there's anything about a cool website that has text on it and you think you could kind of get information out of automatically by using a language model or something there's probably something interesting and different you can do there um another place to look is that there are various leaderboards for the state-ofthe-art on different problems and you can start looking through leaderboards for stuff and see
what you find there um but you know on the other hand the disadvantage of looking at things like leaderboards and past conferences is you sort of uh tend to be trying to do a bit better on a problem someone else has done and that's part of um why you know really often in research it's a clever thing to think of something different perhaps not too far from things that other people have done but somehow different so you'll be able to do something a bit more original and different for what you're doing
um yeah I mean I do just want to go through this a bit quickly um that you know um for sort of decade that I've been doing natural language processing with deep learning there's sort of been a sea change in what's possible um so in the early days of the deep learning um Revival you know most of the work in people's papers were trying to find better deep learning architectures so that would be here is some question answering system I've got an idea of how I could add attention in
some new place or I could add a new um layer into the new network and the the numbers will go up um and um there were lots of papers like that and it was a lot of fun and that's what a lot of good CS2 224n projects did too and people were often able to build systems from scratch that were close to the state-of-the-art um but you know in the last five years your chances of doing this have been become pretty slim frankly um you know you can if you really got a good idea and it's something different than original by all
means but it's kind of hard so most work these days even for people who are professional researchers that you know they're making use of existing large pre-trained models in some way and then once you're doing that that actually sort of fixes a lot of your architectural choices because your large pre- chain neural network has a certain AR architecture and you kind of have to live with it you know you might be able to do interesting things by adapting it with something like low rank adaptation around the side or
something but nevertheless there's sort of constraints on what you want to do so you know for just about any practical project like you've got some data set and you want to understand it and get facts out of it or something like that essentially the only sensible choice is to say I am going to use hugging face um Transformers um which we have a tutorial on coming up ahead and I will load some pre-trained model and I will be running it over the text and then I'll be working out some other stuff I can do on
a top and around that so you know building your own architecture is really only a sensible choice if you can do something in the small which is more a sort of exploring architectures project if you've kind of got an idea of hey I've got an idea for different nonlinearity that I think will work better than using a re let me investigate kind of thing because then you can do small experiments um yeah maybe I won't read out all of this list but um there are lists of sort of some of the ideas of
what's more interesting um now um but you know do be cognizant of the world we're in in terms of scale I mean one of the problems we now have is that people have um seen the latest paper that was being pushed by Deep Mind or whoever um doing some cool graph structured um reasoning search to do things and they turn up and say I want to um do this for my project but a lot of the time if you um read further into the paper you'll find that they were doing it on 32 A1 100s for a month and that's not the
scale of computer that you're going to have available to you in almost any all circumstances maybe they're one or two industry students for the industry students that you can do that if so go for it but for the vast majority of people not likely um so you do have to um do something um that um is practical but you know that practicality is true for vast majority of the people in the world and if you look around in blogs and so on you find lots of people um doing stuff in lightweight ways um and describing how
to do that and that's why methods like parameter efficient fine tuning are really popular because you can do them in lightweight ways um the question related to that and I'll end on this is you know I just want to sort of um sort of mention again you know if you want to you're welcome to use gp4 or Gemini Pro or Claude Opus or any of these models in your project um but you know it has to be then API usage you can't possibly train your own big models I mean even for the models that are
available open source and like those you know for big models you can't even load them into the kind of gpus you have so you know probably you can load a llama 7B model but you can't just load into your G CPU llama 70b model um so you have to be um realistic on that size but you know there's actually now lots of interesting things you can do with API access doing things like in context learning and prompting and exploring that or building larger language model programs around these language model components and you're
certainly encouraged to do that um lots of other things you can do such as analysis projects which look at are these models sexist and racist still or do they have good understanding of analogies or can they interpret love letters or whatever is your topic of Interest lots of things you can do and that's totally allowed um but again you know remember that we'll be trying to evaluate us on what interesting stuff you did um so your project shouldn't be I ran this stuff through gp4 and It
produced great summaries of the documents I am done the question is um what did you do in addition to that to have an interesting research project okay I'll stop there thanks a lot